Tiffany Mario Tami Mario who six ago
okey-dokey oh I've been the voice of
Mario for 26 years now ragazza Louise is
now moving on Donna Lee oh hi i'm
charles martinet I do the voice of Super
Mario here we go whoa
and we talk luigi nevermind haha and why
oh hey about a day yeah oh you wanna eat
that garlic s and I was even donkey kong
one point I am an actor and voice actor
I did gosh 25 years of theater run along
to your body corporate videos circuitry
and semiconductor profit a few film and
television products now feed it all you
know
and then that had the marvelous
beginning of becoming a voice actor and
that's how I started with eat any meat
Mario Mario was first created in 1981 in
a game called Donkey Kong as it got
refined through the years it became
Mario and Princess Peach hey Dean tase
and I came along in 1990 I actually
crashed an audition because I was
catching them as I walked in they were
walking out finished for the day I said
can I read for this and the guy looked
at his watch and goes all right come on
in
you're an Italian plumber from Brooklyn
a character in a video game for Nintendo
called Mario so make up a voice make up
a video game start talking and I thought
to myself video game I don't know
anything about video games and all of a
sudden I hear action I go hello I'm
Mario did make a pizza by together you
go get some sausage I don't get too much
spaghetti
we put spaghetti in the sausage and
pizza and he said you know cut stop
talking there's no more tape
all right thanks we'll be in touch and I
thought that was you know okay there's
the door we'll see you later and I he
calls Nintendo I found out Mario I got
him and that was 26 amazing fantastic
years ago
I know I know Ruby oh look at this world
the character for me brings out the best
in me and so I I love that mean mean
mean I love sharing things too I go to
meet Mario fans and I hear the most
wonderful thing you know the you're the
voice of my childhood I and I used to
play with my dad now I'm playing with my
kids you know and we just it's a way our
family comes together good has been
packed amenities
Mamma Mia you just have fun you know
that's my mantra for life come on weeks
ago they tell more fun I fight you
noises what
[Music]